Somebody help me, please!
Anybody!
What happened?
I had a heart attack.
I had to get a transplant.
Does it feel any different?
Can you tell
it's someone else's?
I just want everything to go
back to the way it was before.
It's just so weird
that someone had to die
in order for me to live.
How are you, Frank?
Thank you, both.
Your daughter,
she saved Sasha's life.
I can't even begin imagining
what you have gone through.
I just want you to know
we're gonna do
everything we can
to keep her memory alive.
Nancy and I have endowed
a scholarship
in Becky's name.
We want to offer
the scholarship to Sasha.
Watch out for that family.
I want to know
who's inside of me.
I'm seeing things.
Things that she saw.
What the hell?
This is getting weird.
I think one day,
we're gonna realize
that this whole
heart attack thing
was the best thing
that happened to you.